America's coldest state with one of the
hottest on the 4th of July and
scientists are sounding the alarm
Anchorage Alaska hit a record 90 degrees
on the holiday with the summer Sun
beating down all day and most of the
night there's little relief Jonathan
Vigliotti is about 50 miles outside
Anchorage at the Byron glacier where the
heat is having a noticeable impact and
good morning to you that's a lie fourth
record 25 degrees above average to put
that all in perspective it's going to be
as hot here today as it is in Miami
these glaciers are a natural air
conditioner reflecting the sun's rays
back into the atmosphere but this state
is heating up at a rate twice as fast as
the rest of the country and scientists
warn that these glaciers can't keep up
Alaska's glaciers weren't enough to cool
off hikers as the nation's Arctic state
baked and tropical like heat from people
sledding in shorts to wildlife like
moose cooling off in backyard sprinklers
America's northernmost frontier at times
resembled Florida's panhandle there's
really no getting around the fact that
our climate is warmed and these are
three events are more likely more likely
says climatologist Brian Brettschneider
because this hot spell is part of a
larger trend in the past 50 years Alaska
has warmed between two to five degrees
and NASA says the state's glaciers are
losing more than two feet in density a
year the warming caused causes of snow
and ice to melt which then frees up more
the ground to absorb more heat and the
water which causes even more heating
which causes more snow and ice to melt
so really it feeds off of itself in a in
a downward spiral that downward spiral
has also been linked to Alaska's growing
wildfires already this year fires have
burned 200,000 more acres of land than
last year and there's still two more
months left in the season marine life
has also shown heat related to stress
with more than a dozen gray whales
washing up many malnourished is Alaska
the country's canary in a coalmine
though it really is for climate change
because everything is so visible here we
need to use this as an opportunity
education-wise and and how we think
about our policy for moving forward for
how we're going to accommodate and
potentially stop warming that's already
occurred and the warming that that may
or may not be baked into the future
globally glaciers are melting five times
faster than they were 50 years ago
meteorologists say it will cool off here
275 degrees by Wednesday but scientists
say these Alaskan heat waves could be
the new normal for CBS this morning I'm
Jonathan Vigliotti on the byron glacier
in Alaska so alarming not people want to
hear it really puts it in perspective
for people think about climate change
anymore Laurie scientists sounded the
telling exactly what I out of them
exactly right